the US government says natural disasters
are worsening because of climate change
the National Climate Assessment compiled
by 13 federal agencies was released
Friday in blunt language the report
warns temperatures in the US could
increase by as much as 12 degrees by the
end of the century it sights humans as
the cause of more than 90% of the
current warming the report says the
effects of climate change could have
dire economic effects potentially
shrinking the US economy by 10 percent
in just the past three years more
frequent and severe storms floods and
wildfires and droughts have cost more
than 400 billion dollars here to discuss
the extraordinary findings is CBS News
climate and weather contributor Jeff
beard le Jeff good morning that ten
percent shrink in the US economy is one
of the things that jumped out to me
because it's not just the climate what's
one thing that really stood out to you
from this report Wow I think it was the
bold emphatic straightforward language
that climate has never changed as fast
as it is since humans have been on this
earth that temperatures haven't changed
as fast as they are since humans have
been on this earth and that it is
emphatically caused by humans and the
burning of fossil fuels there's no
debate left in this report on that but
also that we are the captains of this
ship and there is still time to change
course and take action but we have to do
so very quickly and to that point both
in air quality and ozone depletion we
know we we can make a difference we can
so what can we do well that's a big
question there's a lot that we can do
this is the greatest threat that
humanity has ever faced so I have to be
clear on that and the interesting thing
is it's going to force us to either work
together or it'll bring our demise so
we're gonna have to come together
respect each other respect the earth
this is our sustenance become
sustainable or as a species if we don't
evolve as fast as the climate
environment involves then we will perish
but we can do things you know so I think
it starts with people like us the little
people the grassroots efforts it starts
with us just being Morris
back full of each other and this planet
and realizing that our life depends on
this it's making the little changes at
home that rub off on other people it's
not like if you drive an electric car
you were going to save the world but if
you drive an electric car and you save
one or two hundred dollars a month on
gas your neighbors will see that there
enables will see that if everyone starts
to be more respectful of the earth which
we depend upon I think that that makes
its way up the food chain to businesses
and to our government and we have to
hold our leaders accountable so don't do
business with companies that aren't good
stewards of this world and don't elect
leaders that aren't good stewards of
this earth as this report makes clear if
it's not just about the environment it's
about the economy I've been hearing this
from economists for years economic
effects of this could be catastrophic
we're already seeing that I mean huge
storms over the past couple years four
hundred billion dollars worth of damage
just in the past few years or so and
that's just from extreme storms which
are going to get worse but as health
gets worse because of allergies because
of asthma because of Zika because of
Lyme disease that creates a burden on
our economy as we start to heat up and
dry out parts of the Americas and
especially places like the Midwest the
deep Southwest farmland that will cause
more damage to crops and we won't see as
much productivity it's all a snowball
effect it's all connected this
conversation will continue Jeff
absolutely appreciate you being here